it is gross what for one it my shoes are
i have to throw them out
it's disgusting you're dirty now though
oh
oh now you're grossed out of me don't
touch me now now we don't need
um but on all seriousness are you okay
with staying here and not coming back
[Music]
so i don't know if you heard but that
guy he actually just said in spanish
audios
that guy just did yeah he did
a man walks by and says adios which is a
derogatory
homophobic slur in mexico well i wish i
would have known i probably would have
said something back to him
and then what the fight or something
goes down
i've never been in public in florida and
someone has been nasty
like that to my dad
you can go on somewhere else no no i'm
getting pissed off
stop i don't want us to get hurt
i really hope it is an eye opener for my
dad it's been for me because
we aren't used to this i really i wanted
to punch that guy in the face
like that really makes my blood boil
don't let it hurt your feelings it's
just ridiculous people are so blind
[Music]